but i'd like to welcome you today to the
keynote presentation in the defense
preservatives I am Bob Woodard of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots for more
information please visit www.der steve
is the vice president of global
microbiology and fermentation rmd for
the estee lauder companies he has been
with s day for over 25 years all with
the microbiology and fermentation lab
his primary responsibilities are in the
area of cosmetic preservation and
advising the chemists on new
formulations other responsibilities
include developing new active
ingredients through fermentation
advising manufacturing on cleaning and
sanitation procedures and assisting
quality assurance and manufacturing when
problems arise please join me in
welcoming speeds through this
presentation thank you I will now turn
the presentation over to him good
morning can you hear me we had a we had
some issues
good morning my name is Steve snicker
and again i'm the chief microbiologist
for estee lauder in charge of cosmetic
in charge of preservation and RD my my
other role is looking for a new active
ingredients and fermentation and today
I'm going to talk about cosmetic
preservation and as you can see my title
it talks about in defense of preserves
and you might be asking why is why is
the word defense in there and it's
because preserves around the globe are
being scrutinized in just about every
marketplace from a legal standpoint a
regulatory standpoint public perception
perception standpoint and because of
this scrutiny the number of modules that
we have available for use in cosmetics
pharmaceuticals the paint industry is
being reduced monthly so it really is a
fight and in defense that preserves are
required they're needed they're needed
to ensure the stability and the safety
of our products for admission standpoint
you know every cosmetic manufacturer and
whether it be cosmetics and pharma has
the new responsibilities relative the
quality of their products we have to
ensure to make sure that our products
are free from bacteria during
manufacturing during filling at the same
time and also once those products in the
hands of the consumer many of our
products in the industry in the cosmetic
industry are the stability programs go
out three to five years so we have to
ensure that those products will stay
free of contamination during the life of
that prop once in the hands of the
consumer and to achieve that goal we
have to make sure that our products are
properly preserved or that they are
properly protected which might be too
protective packaging and I'll talk about
that in a little while there also has to
be a GMP quality program in place which
includes proper environmental monitoring
and these two must go hand in hand
because you could have a formula that
was adequately preserved past all
challenge testing but if the quality is
not there in manufacturing or in the
filling operation then you do run the
risk of contamination the same as if a
product is under preserved but your
quality systems were in place because
we're not making sterile products or
using sterile raw materials that low
level of bacteria may start to grow out
because the level of preservation in
that formulation is not adequate to kill
off that low level of bacteria so again
these two programs have to go and hand
in hand to make a quality product so
this isn't justify of my discussion
today preservation and protection and I
talked about aqueous crocs that all
aqueous products have to be properly
preserved because again there's water
and where there's water there is our
moisture there is that chance of
contamination and for bacteria survive
and grow out even an 80-minute powder if
you had a proc that had a high of
moisture content there is that chance
that bacteria to get in there and become
contaminated and I think this is a good
slide which is indicative indicative of
that potential growth if you had you
know five cells at time zero zero five
cfu of e.coli within seven hours it
could end up in the tens of millions and
this could happen with any cosmetic
pharmaceutical proc whether it be a
mascara a skincare product he saw was
not properly preserved this sort of
scenario can easily exist and this is a
good example to on why we need proper
preservation and proper quality control
in during manufacturing because again
eat it could easily grow out into these
high numbers
and I think the next slide is even is
even more indicative of the potential of
what could happen and it really is
pretty much black and white on the left
side you have a skincare cream in a wide
office jar which is properly preserved
as you can see this there's no bacteria
there's no mold being shown but on the
right side you have that same cream
which is under preserved and clearly
there's mold growing on the surface of
the product and pretty much everybody on
this call has probably opened their open
up a loaf of bread at one point in time
and found one modes for growing on a
slice of bread and you've thrown that
whole loaf of bread out just some an
aesthetic standpoint thinking that it's
not good for you well what do you think
would happen if a woman opened up a jar
of cream and saw this mold growing on
top of their product they would never go
back and buy that cream ever again you
may go back and buy that loaf of bread
to say no it's you know it's just one
slice but the probability that they
would go back to the back to the the
market go back to a store and buy this
cream ever again it would probably never
happen so this is why this example is
clearly why we need preservatives or
probably preserve products product
protection is a multi-faceted approach I
mean the the main function is through
chemical preservatives and it always
will be as long as we continue to
develop these sorts of products and i'll
talk about chemical preserves those
ingredients that are classified and only
deliver a preservative activity to a
formulation and in in the last few years
multifunctional ingredients with other
things that are classified as
multifunctional have also been used to
deliver some form of preservation to a
formula and why they're classified as
multifunctional because not only do they
have antimicrobial activity but they
also deliver some other attributes like
you beckon see as a solvent as a soluble
Iser deodorant agent and i'll talk about
each of these different class of
products further down in my in my in my
presentation product protection can also
come from physicochemical factors such
as pH reduced water activity
manufacturing filling temperatures which
creates an environment is hostile to
microbial growth for those are the our
view who are familiar with I so we've
just recently in the last few years
published a guideline is 029 621 which
talks about these physicochemical
factors and we've classified a certain
list of products which we considered low
risk because because either the pH is
too low or too high or the water
activity is very low or the filled
temperatures are so high that they'll
kill off any bacteria that might be
present in the formulation from a
cosmetic standpoint from an aqueous
cosmetic standpoint these
physicochemical factors may play a major
role when developing a preserver system
because if you can lower the water
activity with a pH low enough then all
you have to worry about is is an
antifungal Frain hi just rocks they play
a major role in determining the level of
testing the level of preservation and
the criteria used to test those certain
products and i'll talk about iso 296 21
further on in my presentation and
finally packaging you know you can you
can fill a product into a package which
minimizes the contact between the
consumer and the product you can pretty
much make a product that will stay free
of bacteria turning the life of the
product and again I'll expand on that
further down and and talk about ISIL 11
9 30 so just to recap this last section
preservatives continued to play the
major role or chemical deserves continue
to play the major role in ensuring that
products remain free of bacteria
multi-functional because of the the
the decrease and acceptable preserves is
playing a larger role that and the
multifunctional in combination with
preserves can conform the very
efficacious formula preservative
potentiates again with with observes are
enhancing the activity the
physicochemical factors and packaging
all play a role in cross protection I'm
going to talk about definition because
I'm going to try to distinguish between
preservation multifunctional and
potentiate errs and show that there is a
significant difference between these
three different categories of products
and I'll explain why as we go on
preservation is the process by which a
chemical or physical agent prevents of
biological deterioration of materials
and this comes out of block disinfection
sterilization and preservation which is
pretty much the Bible when it comes to
disinfection and in the European Union
preservative is classified that chemical
which is exclusively used or mainly
intend to inhibit the development of
microorganisms and these positive this
positive list is listed in annex five so
if you are marking it product in urine
one it has to have a challenge test to
show that is properly preserved and two
you have to have a chemical that is on
an x5 on your eyeliner on your
ingredient label to show that it is
properly preserved this is a list that
my friend David Steinberg he has been
publishing this list of frequency of use
preservatives for 30 years for as long
as I can remember it comes out every
other year he looks at all the formulas
that are registered with the FDA and
and classifies the different which
preserves are being used this is both
the United States and Canada and what
I'd add to this list in column number
two is the the type of preservative
which it is whether it's in paraben and
iso theophylline from a live release or
halogenated or organic acid and as you
can see that will leave the
preservatives in yellow are those where
there's been a significant increase or
frequency views over time that's why
except for benzyl alcohol which really
is a fragrance item all of these
molecules only have one function and
that is preservation except for the
organic acids every one of these
compounds is on the some foam of
regulatory environmental or safety
review every one of these chemical
classifications have some gray cloud
over them which is one in the use or or
not giving them a clean bill of health
and because of the restrictions on the
parabens on methylisothiazolinone method
i ugly the use of phenoxyethanol Haziq
significance phenoxyethanol and benzyl
alcohol are showing significant
increases why because they don't have
that regulatory restriction or that i'll
call it that gray cloud hanging over
their head but we the industry whether I
see the cosmetic industry the paint
industry or Pharma can only simply
cannot survive with only two classes of
approved preservatives in our arsenal to
help preserve our products
this is the objective of my talk you
know 15 years ago if I go back for a
second 15 years ago every one of these
preserves was used without any
restrictions from now by releases
parabens we did we had a full arsenal of
preserves but today like I said every
one of these has some form of limitation
so you know we the global cosmetic
industry you know we need to make sure
that we have a full arsenal we need to
continue to defend these different
molecules find new molecules and improve
the arsenal that we have otherwise we
are going to be and clean some serious
issue because of the restrictions on
many of these mainstream preservatives
multifunctional ingredients of those
things classified as multi-functions is
picking up the slack many many companies
are using both a functional in
combination with conventional systems to
ensure preservative efficacy and
ensuring that their products are
adequately preserved the problem is that
many companies whether they be raw
material suppliers or finished good
houses are making preservative-free
claims even though they may contain both
a functional ingredients were those
things like I said before which are not
on an x5 or on the positive list by
doing that you really are creating
issues with not only the companies that
are doing it but also with the industry
because of because of labeling and lingo
to requirements you're not you not
meeting the requirements which was set
down by the European Union to ensure
preservative efficacy so you really do
need to have on your label a
preservative which is on nx5 and you may
have in combination with many of these
multi-functions but the preserver free
claim is not doing anyone
it's not giving anyone a clear advantage
I don't know how many people are buying
a product because it says paraben free
or preservative free or I've seen where
suppliers have put on their label we
don't use dangerous biosigns like the
other guy we cannot continue to add fuel
to this fire that preservatives are bad
because as I've shown they clearly are
required and needed to ensure that we
are making safe zones in 1976 the
seventh amendment was born and what it
said was that there had to be a
recognized challenge test in the dossier
or the documentation that was submitted
with that proc in that formula into the
European Union and there must be a
conventional preservative on that label
in combination with that formulation so
these two again go hanging in there has
to be efficacy data and there has to be
an approved observe and by making by
only using multi-functions you're
basically breaking this law a second
reason for using the multifunctional is
where is that potential to reduce the
risk of sensitization as i showed in the
frequency of use chart the amount of the
amount of phenoxy fo which is being used
in formulation is significantly
increasing because of those other broad
spectrum preserves being restricted for
use there was recently Danish study
where they made note that phenoxy is
increasing around the world and they
made the claim that there is that
potential increase of sensitization and
what I'm trying to prove here is that if
you combine the multifunctional with a
conventional preserva system you have
the potential of low in the level of the
conventional preserves plus in ensuring
preservative efficacy
I wonder if I should take a question I
don't guess there's nothing on there
you know many many cosmetic ingredients
have been you have been recognized as
multifunctional for years whether the
alcohols essential oils EDTA as a key
later and surfactants and today I'm
going to talk about to which really have
become mainstream in the area of
preservation first time I talk about
glycols I'm going to talk about feeling
like Oh a little bit in the future I'm
going to talk about it and also that
Kepler glycol but beauty like all
propylene glycol has been used in the
industry I think I'm dating back to the
50s it was used in the past for
improving the solubility of meth
apartment or the parabens it was used to
ensure that the parents stayed in the
water phase and did not migrate into the
oil phase it was used for emotional
stability especially during freestone to
ensure that the prof is not going to
separate and it was used as a
preservative potentiate ER to deliver
that antimicrobial into the cell wall
and enhance the killing activity about
15 years ago excellent glycolic peddling
glycol were delivered to the marketplace
again they were any time they were
multifunctional they had moisturizing
effect they'd American capabilities and
they were also used stabilized preserves
the propylene glycol during glycol were
used in the past at say six to eight
percent the hex plaintiff pennilyn
glycol is now being used at the one to
two percent range and now the most
recent one is capital glycol which has
strong antimicrobial activity it also
works at the American moisturizer and
the level of use is able from point five
to one percent
cap from glencoe otherwise known as 12
octane dial it comes in as a as a waxy
substance it easily melts at room
temperature it has both antimicrobial
moisturizing and you met Kim properties
it can also be used as a sauce pfizer or
delivery system and the key here is that
it does have broad spectrum activity it
really has limited antifungal activity
but it's it's not impacted by pH so it
works across all product types against
all ph types and if you combine it with
an organic acid you pretty much though
to have an ingredient which will kill
off bacteria yeast and most work that
was done by summarize a number of years
ago show that the capital glycol will
disrupt the cell membrane and basically
will blow open the cell membrane it's
also shows miss synergistic f standpoint
that will help inside the lipid
insoluble antimicrobials penetrate the
cell wall and kill the bacteria and the
benefit here with the capital glycol is
a does stay at the water oil interface
between the auto phase and the water
face it will not migrate into the oil
phase and but it stays in the water
phase where it's needed where the
bacteria might grow it's used in
combination with just about every
conventional preserver system that's out
there today and will boost its activity
it will lower the level of preservation
of conventional preserves that are
needed in combination with the capital
glycol and you get very good activity
right
this is work that we had done in the lab
a number of years ago where we
investigated the order of addition when
adding the Catholic like old because
many of the chemists would they didn't
know whether to add the oil phase the
water phase or post emulsification and
what we did was we tested against the
five different challenge test pools
recognized by the USP and as you can see
up here we start off with this is this
is a graph for e.coli we start off with
10 to the 6 e coli and the yellow line
is post multiplication at 45 degrees the
blue line is in the oil phase and the
red line is in the water phase and as
you can see we went from from 10 to the
6 down to about 10 to the 2 within two
days and then we had complete kill
within one week as compared to the oil
phase and the water phase so we show
with that by an impost most occation
once the emotion had been put together
cold and say 45 degrees we had the
quickest way to kill and this this this
testing was done for all five pools and
pretty much for every case the post
emulsification worked the best and as
you can see we did have a six log
reduction within one week so it is a
very good antimicrobial the next want to
talk about is ethylhexyl glycerin again
it's been used for deodorants it does
have a multi functional approach it's
both used as an emollient and fritzy met
concede it does have synergy with with
parabens sonakshi at those and iso file
clean and is also being marketed in that
position
this is a very good graph of showing the
multifunctional approach and its energy
with phenoxyethanol so here you have the
Green Line is the fo x closer by itself
and as you can see against pseudomonas
aeruginosa there is no kill whatsoever
so it pretty much stayed at ten to the
six for the seven days we then we'll get
any point nine percent phenoxyethanol
and it took 24 hours for it to get
completed four to achieve complete kill
but when you combine the point one
percent ethylhexyl glycerin with the
point nine phenoxyethanol within three
hours you had complete kill so you had a
six wild reduction with in three hours
when you combine those two ingredients
together which clearly shows the synergy
between those two ingredients the same
thing goes for aspergillus for moles
point one percent evidence of glycerin
had no effect until out 168 hours point
nine percent phenoxyethanol same thing
almost no activity but when you combine
the tube within 24 hours you had a six
log reduction and I want to thank when
the subtle with the choking for this
data in conclusion the use of
multifunctional greens can help reduce
the amount of conventional preserves in
a fund elation and still guarantee
efficacy and safety it also shows that
these multifunctional greens do have
both antimicrobial activity but other
benefits when egg to a cosmetic emotion
they're not only preservatives the next
class of compounds I want to talk about
are those things considered as
preservative potentiates and many people
when talking about these multifunctional
I think there's some confusion and I
want to try to set the groundwork
between a potentiate er a booster and a
multifunctional because in this case a
potentially or something that that will
enhance the
microb late agent but does not have
activity on its own but will increase
the susceptibility of the microbial cell
to that active ingredient and again this
came out of Russell in 1992 this
definition three of the ingredients I
want to talk about it EDTA which again
has been around for years butylene
glycol again going back to the 50s and
13 propane dial which is a corner eyes
palio which is made by dupont eight mile
edpa has been has been used for years
this reference down here below asking
about which one is better than a 2 vs na
three versus na for I found in a society
of industrial microbiology book I think
dated back to nineteen fifty four it was
an obscure reference and it's funny
because the chemists always come in
asking which one should they use in a
twenty three and a four and clearly the
data showed that the na two had the best
activity which was also tied to the pH
but basically it does have activity
against gram-negative bacteria
especially through the motifs there are
reported cases where it will enhance the
activity of EDTA plus other ingredients
when tested against fungus and it will
help against developing antimicrobial
resistance from a from a multi
functional standpoint it does help in
minimizing fragrance oxidation
discoloration or yellowing and keep up
keep a clear solution could if to ensure
that there's no precipitation to the
metal ion impurities or kicking out and
it works basically works better in an
acid pH range we use it in pretty much
every formulation that we have to
protect against pseudomonas
butylene glycol like I said before has
been used since the 50s it's been used
to help stabilize emotions it is it's
worked in combination with parabens and
phenom CFL to keep them into the water
phase to help potentiate activity
against bacteria on its own I've seen
reports up to fifty percent butylene
glycol does not have antimicrobial
activity it is it does have static
activity but it's not a biocide on its
own and it will help minimize the loss
of fragrance over time the most recent
one is damaia propane dial and there's
many benefits to this this raw material
it's being produced by by de podkayne
while in joint venture and in Wilmington
Delaware if a fermentation product comes
from corn it's a natural derived corn
derivative it does have you reckon
activity it can be used as a as in the
most of our an episode of booster and it
does have both antimicrobial and anti
bacterial testing when tested against
it's the CTF a challenge test which is a
28 day challenge against the five
different bacterial pools it does show
complete kill when tested against is MIA
at a hundred percent and when compared
to propylene and Gulen glycol it has the
same degree of activity but again that's
neat that's a hundred percent the
benefit here is through skin hydration
and moisturization and for us in the
cosmetic industry this is important
because you know that is that is what we
are trying to achieve with many of our
emotions and and skin products and as
you can see when compared the survey of
propane dial 2 billion glycol to
propylene glycol and the control this
may have performed the best as far as
moisturization and hydration
so this is a key benefit because here we
had a glycol that was that was a natural
substance because it came from corn it
was a fermentation product product it
wasn't it wasn't a phenolic or or course
that's or synthesized but it had these
benefits secondly the other key thing
here was they compared it they compared
the samaya to propylene glycol and from
a structural standpoint the propane dial
and propylene glycol are basically the
same it's a 13 verses a 12 bond but the
significance here is as you can see by
the graph and I know it might be a
little cloudy and I apologize for that
but as you can see when you compared in
an RIPT which is a which measures
irritation on the skin it is six week
study that when you compare 25% of
propylene glycol to twenty-five percent
in sameah 8.2 percent of the population
had an adverse reaction when you
increase the fifty percent propylene
glycol twenty one percent of the
population had a reaction at a stinging
or redness versus the fifth extensive
ayyah and when you got to seventy-five
percent propylene glycol twenty two
percent of the population had an adverse
reaction vs. ameya so for us again from
a from a skincare company standpoint
because it does not elicit an adverse
reaction it does have antimicrobial
activity or sanji there and also
delivers a moisturization effect this is
a key ingredient for the cosmetic
industry and it would be clearly
considered a multifunctional so in
conclusion for this part of the talk you
know the use of these ingredients as
sort of touches can only approve the
executor of our conventional preserve
system but they also improve the overall
safety again by by reducing adverse
reactions not a listening a positive
reaction so there is a complete package
here when look at these types of
material
and there are others up there are others
out there I'm just highlighting these
two or three the last section here is to
talk about packaging and the role that
packaging plays in Prague protection
because if you can minimize contact
between the consumer between the
environment and your product then there
is no chance that that the the mold that
might be in the air or the bacteria that
might be in the air or the bacteria that
might be on the woman's fingers or man's
fingers that matter cannot come in
contact with that product you know if
many times you've seen with a shampoo
bottle people are trying to unscrew the
top they add some water to try to get
that last couple of drops out of that
shampoo bottle so if you can if you can
crimp that neck to ensure that that net
that that that top does not come off
then you can any you can fill it under
the best conditions that proc will stay
sterile for the life of the product this
applies to both storage conditions and
finished goods if you can fill that
product during the manufacturing stage
into a container which does not come in
contact with the environment with the
air again it'll stay sterile as long as
it stays within that package and to do
that especially during manufacturing and
production you have to make sure that
you're using sanitary and sterile
procedures and follow all possible gmps
if we if we compared risk factors to the
final packaging you know we would
consider pumps opthalmic tube tubes to
the one-way valves as lower risk because
you're minimizing the contact between
the consumer and that product there's
even though if there are bacteria on a
person's fingers there's no way with an
ophthalmic tip two or one with a one-way
valve that that prop would that that the
bacteria or the air would get sucked
back into that tube and potential
possibly contaminate that product
for a moderate potential risk tubes
bottles Fulton pens those things where
the office at the end of that package is
small it minimizes the chance of
contamination so those of you who don't
know what a flow-through pennies they
are like a lipstick case with a sponge
tip applicator or a brush on the end
where you are basically driving that
product into that tip and then apply it
onto the skin when you have these full
depends which sponge tip applicator with
the sponge itself then you are creating
an environment with the with the small
offices on that package where there is a
potential for bacteria to grow and the
highest risk would be a white office
drawer a four ounce jar or a sponge tip
applicator because again with a sponge
tip you are transferring any bacteria
that might be on a person's face back
onto that sponge and those pores are
creating a good environment where we're
moisture bacteria the Steven or the oils
from personal space in combination with
the bacteria it's just a perfect
environment for bacteria to grow so so
that's where packaging you know we can
play a major role in ensuring product
safety throughout the life of the
product I spoke early on about the ISO
guidelines and I so 11 9 30 which was
published a couple years ago the
evaluation antimicrobial protection of a
cosmetic product it combines the risk
assessment with a challenge test
criteria or a challenge test method and
a challenge size criteria the key here
is that with this criteria you are using
the final stages to to use packaging as
the final pass/fail criteria even if you
had a product that did not pass the
challenge if you can show that in the
package that it was being sold in that
the risk to the consumer was minimal
then it would get a passing grade and
this is the only method that I know of
where
Packaging plays a major role in the
overall criteria and relief criteria for
a product so again if you want to look
at the the interaction between packaging
and risk assessment and preservation
this would be a good reference for you
when we talked about the physicochemical
factors I I want to reference the ISO
296 to one where the physicochemical
factors play a major role in determining
if a product is a low risk low risk
formulation and when I say low risk
there are many of these which do not
require any caffeine or do not require
preservation and a good example that
would be a would be a lipstick prom
because more often than not its
manufacturing and filled at very high
temperatures 85c it's all waxes and oils
there is no water there and any bacteria
that may have accumulating transferred
from your lips onto the lipstick would
not grow because because there's no
place for the bugs to hide they would
only live and survive on the outside of
that lipstick and only survive if there
was muy sure and once that moisture
dried up then those then those bacteria
would would go off so for those types of
products the lipsticks high pH products
high alcohol products we considered an
exempt and exempt from testing so they
do not require preservation they may
they may require minimal testing and
again the physicochemical factors play a
major role in determining which are
tested and which are not not tested so
this might be a reference you may want
to look at so to conclude my talk you
know product protection is a
multi-faceted approach to ensure
long-term equality and stability of a
cosmetic product it is basically comes
mostly from from preservation but
because of the scrutiny of preservation
we've had to find other means of trying
to preserve and ensure the stability and
safety of our products
preserves our faith and beta scrutiny
around the world and that goes for the
cosmetic industry pharmaceutical
industry the paint industry we're all in
the same boat because of May in many
cases because of public perception
because people you know read an article
read on the internet that a certain
class of chemicals are bad and then they
see that on the label that this product
contains that class of preservatives and
therefore they don't buy it or they say
oh I can't buy this because it has XYZ
in there and it's going to it's going to
cause a problem and I keep on saying to
people as well what would be the
alternative as I shown that for-profit
is under preserved there is a high
chance of bacterial fungal growth so
there is that there's that there's a
trade-off between preservation and
potential adverse reactions due to an
eye infection because something is not
properly preserved so it really is a
balance that the use of multifunction
greens has increased as a mainstream
form of protection and they should not
be classified as conventional preserves
because as I've shown many of these
clearly do have many different
attributes to their chemistry's and both
packaging and physicochemical properties
can play a major role in the overall
protection of a product so as I stated
it is a multi-faceted approach and we
have to start thinking outside the box
we have to continue to defend those
molecules we have available to us we
have to look at look for new molecules
we have to ensure that the message that
we get that the message that is sent to
the consumer is one of sound science and
in defense of preservatives that they
are not as bad as some of the people on
the internet might think they are and
the word that's being spread and we the
industry have to keep on continuing to
defend not just not into the class of
our chemistry a class of product but we
have to defend preservatives as a whole
we here to defend the safety of not only
the industry but also the consumer
that's buying our products are there any
questions okay I see you now the
question is would you please comment on
the outlook for probiotics enzymes and
other natural fermentation products to
be used for preservatives functions in
future formulations and are these
classes being added to EU positive lists
we have done a lot of work with
probiotics here we've done a lot of work
with lactobacillus we have seen some
activities but it's not a broad-spectrum
activity it's very limited you have to
remember that that cosmetics are very
complex many formulations may have 25 30
different raw materials in them and to
use something like a like a probiotic or
you know the lactic acid or some of the
small molecules that are being produced
by through probiotics they would
probably be bound up by some of the
chemicals that are in those formulations
so I don't see them as a as a means of
preservation enzymes on the other hand
there are a few that i know of that that
are working very well there's the lack
of peroxidase glucose oxidase system
which is a very good antimicrobial which
is being used right now in the cosmetic
industry I don't know any other enzymes
that are being used by the industry
there is some food grade enzymes that
we've looked at but again many of those
food grade enzymes are used as static
activity they're not final so they're
using the food industry to keep bacteria
in check not to kill them off we look at
a few of the collected niacin and again
it did not perform it may perform well
in a single matrix system like a food
but in a complex matrix like cosmetics
it would probably easily get bound up by
one of the
in that formulation the EU positivist
it's very difficulty that's why there's
people looking going out looking for new
antimicrobials to do the safety testing
to do the tox testing on a new
antimicrobial or new preservative is
very expensive and to recoup your your
costs we just don't know if a company
would be able to recoup their investment
but we are working with the industry
okay that this is probably a nice and a
dropout recovery but I just want to say
one thing if there's any question about
how to submit questions click on the Q&A
button and Laurel after the presentation
window and type your question or comment
into the box that appears on the screen
by our next question is from a troop
charlaine beauty at university of delhi
south campus this question is do you
think some of these preservatives may
advance the development of antibiotic
resistant to microbes any data on this
yes we the industry again the difference
between preservatives and and
antimicrobial antibiotic resistance they
work on different mechanisms of action
preserve a mostly worked on a broad
approach onto the cell membrane where
antibiotics will work on just a single
target target within the cell membrane
so the ability for bacteria to develop a
resistance resistance to a preserve I
know work has been done in the past and
we've just not seen it we've we looked
at night when i say we i say we the
industry not me the estee lauder it does
not it does not happen again because of
that that multiply both assassin
approach on the cell membrane so it's
really not a concern of ours they
succeed in that next question from Lucia
Gandhi the dow chemical company
do the flower and others extracts have
true preservative activity or is it just
a height you know same and in 20 because
when you go to they probably do have
preserved activity you know when you go
to the ASM medium when you go to the
American Society of microbiology me and
you see these posters where people have
found you know certain extracts that
have antimicrobial activity and they've
they've done work in their lab to show
kill you know in a test tube in a petri
dish it probably works very well but
again like I said once you take that
extract and you put it into a cosmetic
formulation all that activity gets lost
based up because of the complex emotions
that that we have in cosmetics they may
work well in a water system or in a bra
system or an a in a single dimensional
system but once you get into a complex
make sure matrix like it like a cosmetic
product or a pharmacist across then all
that activity gets gets down by one of
those ingredients you know I ain't going
there anything with actual presentation
people talk about natural preservatives
I don't know of any natural
preservatives because everything at some
point time has to be synthesized at a
large scale they may be nature identical
people can say that parabens unnatural
yes you can find parabens out in the
environment but those chemicals that
were using in industry today they are
synthetic they are manufactured on large
scale in a chemical plant some place in
the world so there truly are no natural
preservatives that is hype
well thank you yes thank you did it and
if there are no more questions you can
wait one minute here to see if there are
any more questions if there are no more
questions I would like to once again
thank students for his presentation and
sleep if you have any final comments
you'd like to make I just you know for
those of you who are in in in the
industry who are in the cosmetic
industry I tell people to be careful of
you know making the preservative free
claim be careful of criticizing other
people's preservatives or or if you hear
that you know a preservative is has a
bad rap or has negative press against it
I recommend that you go in the
literature and and see if you can
substantiate and confirm that activity
and i don't mean through the internet I
mean to it a true scientific journal of
toxicology contact dermatitis you know
noted references that would validate
those preservatives and their safety
profiles well Stephen another question
has come here from lillian gunners and
the question is which factor of a
multi-faceted approach to improve the
preservative activity could maintain
physicochemical and immune properties in
the skin
I'm pretty much the pH I mean you know
that's one thing that you can control
the best if you can keep the pH of your
products down on the asset side then you
can really then balance out the level
and type of preserve that you may need
for your formulation and again if you
keep it on the low side you are in
balance with the physiological pH of the
skin which is around 662 so if you can
keep in the 5526 range one you are
benefiting your emotion because at that
pH range bacteria have a hard time for
growing and you'd only have to worry
about yeast and mold and two would be
more compatible would be with the
microflora of your skin okay well once
again Stephen thank you for that a great
great talk and we really appreciate it
I'd also like to thank the audience for
participating today and and before we
before we sign off I'd like to announce
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through februari
2016 you will receive an email from lab
roots flirting you when this Web cast
will be of yet available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event once again thank you
very much and we'll see you next time
goodbye thank you